what's your fam's reaction like to
everything that's happening with you
right now
like to the success that your music is
is having
um well my mom really loves it a lot my
dad does too my dad just um he
he's a little more disconnected with
like social media and just like overall
just stuff like that
um so he'll like freak out every now and
then whenever um
like my cousins or whatever
are like like trying to like talk to me
on the phone or whatever and like show
their friends or something like
um so he'll be like what like what is
this
like i'm like dude turn the radio on for
like five seconds man
[Laughter]
it's like actually a legit thing now
like yeah
but like um but like my mom like dude
check this out
yeah my mom like
made me this oh sorry she made me this
book
and it's got like all this stuff from
like the beginning of like
me doing stuff and it's like all
screenshots from
instagram whoa yeah she's like
super proud that's awesome yeah she's
like
trying to make sure i like remember like
everything and like
which i i definitely am especially
because she has like screenshots of like
like everything of like placements on
spotify and like billboard and all this
stuff it was kind of cool i was looking
through this the other day
and um yeah it's really sweet she's
she's awesome and it's so funny that you
you gotta tell your dad like yo turn on
the radio
because your song like because falling
at least you could not turn on the radio
without hearing it
yeah like i think he's like realizing
that too
um he's like he's like realizing that
too but like
um like recently like he would he would
like
say certain things i'm like i'm like dad
like like
i you know like i'm working on like
trying not to i don't really know how to
explain it um
like i'm trying like i try not to like
be like
like yeah bro like i'm all over a rodeo
bro but like i'm just like dad
like it's actually like it falling's
like doing well you know what i'm saying
so
and like past life is going up there now
too so it's
yeah it's i'm like yeah bro
so i think i find it funny like you
gotta explain to him
what's going on with you but then when
you like in that explanation do you
reflect on what's happening to you too
are you just like this is kind of crazy
like
after however many years of wanting it
and putting in work to put this music
out
that this is going on and happening for
you right now yeah i mean
i think like with my dad too like i
think he knows like i think he knows i
just don't think
he realized until like the like the
the recent song came out how like like
successful it started being um yeah
so um yeah dude
i mean i reflect on it i've been
reflecting on it a lot this week
especially because like i came
in i'm trying to get a lot of my stuff
out of here
um just in case like my dad like moves
or whatever i just want to make sure i
got all of my stuff
and then i like found this book that my
mom got me or made me for christmas
um and then yeah dude i've been
reflecting a lot oh and my friend has
this thing on his instagram
um that he just made and he went through
all his archives of and we've been
friends best friends for like
11 years and he went through all his
archives of like
um instagram stories and stuff um
and he's got it like back for the past
like two years
and it's just like me and him chilling
in the studio like working on like this
song or like
and then when we would go to la for the
first time ever and then when we went to
new york for the first time ever
and like just all these little things
and like shows that we would do
when there's like 15 people there and
just like he has like all this stuff
documented
um on his on his instagram
so yeah i think i'm going to do that too
because i have a lot of those so i'm
going to make and
he he titled like the highlights you
know what i'm talking about
yeah yeah of course like never give up
and it's like a
like a storyline it's really cool do you
think it's
do you feel like you have to like what
your mom did for you with that photo
album do you feel like you have to keep
record of this stuff because things move
so quickly
yeah i feel like too i feel like like if
the
like if it wasn't quarantine right now
like i feel like i would be
um seeing things a lot more firsthand
so like right now just in this weird
section of life where it's like things
are like
really happening for me but it just like
it and it feels like it but at the same
time it doesn't
like we're not on tour we're not like
doing these things and
i'm like kind of just sitting at the
house and like seeing
like numbers on a piece of paper a
little bit um
and then and i see like interaction
online and everything going up but i'm
like really uh like for whatever reason
like
the internet kind of like messes with my
head a lot sometimes
um so i'll get off and i'll like ghost
it for a few weeks
um or at least i'll try um
and then like yeah so i
i haven't really like like understood
everything yet but
i'll go and i'll look at things and i'm
i have to remind myself like oh you know
what it has only been like
like six months you know like and things
are
insanely different than they were like i
don't know in october
last year um like things are so much
different and
and i remind myself and like everything
you know is
better you know but i i start to
remember like yo
i love the process too like i miss
little times where we were just in this
sweaty ass
garage studio where there was like no
no ac and stuff like sometimes i'll miss
that stuff
um like yeah it's just like it
reminds me to just be
be try to be more present in everything
yeah
you worked with uh phineas on past life
right
yeah phineas caroline um pinel and like
a bunch of other people yeah
um what's it like yeah sorry go on
oh yeah i was just i was just gonna say
like um it was like
a really fun collaborative song to work
on um
and then you know selena
blessed the track and obviously is
fantastic um like she's
she's just really good so and then
phineas is just a musical genius and
caroline is as well so yeah
i like how like your description of
selena is that she's just like really
good
like when you got the word
like when you got the word that she was
going to like first of all how did that
even happen like
that she got involved with the song yeah
i was actually in the
airport bro and like we had already like
done the session and everything and then
i talked to
to my anr and he was like oh yeah i
think like selena was interested
and like in like maybe doing something
and then like so much at that time when
we talked about it was happening you
know we were
this was like pre-quarantine um and
like we were still doing like in-person
radio
tours and stuff like that um where we
would
go like talk to radio stations and that
was so fun like
i missed that actually um and then
just like we were doing shows and stuff
like that so everything was happening so
in my mind i was like cool
that'd be really sick if it happens it
happens i would love her to get on the
song
obviously um and then like a few months
went by because
you know nobody really expected corona i
think to get this bad
um and then like
he i was in the airport and then charlie
texted me he's like hey
check your text and it just said past
life
sg vocals and um and i
i didn't know what i wasn't thinking
about it because it hadn't really
crossed my mind that much
and i listened to it and it sounded like
she recorded it on like a
apple headphone or something but it
still sounded good like she still
sounded fantastic
um but uh he was like yeah they just
sent that to make sure
you know that like they still want to do
that and then that's when it started
becoming real
and then i was just like oh dude this is
crazy and then um
like they set up a whole studio in her
house and everything
um and like obviously i don't i mean she
probably worked on a lot of stuff too
but um
like i know like they set up the studio
and she
like cut the vocals and we like
facetimed a few times and
just like uh we just were talking about
like the song
and just like got on the same page and
just like we're really
like just talking about ideas and stuff
like that
she's so sweet too like she's just like
really really a sweet person
yeah and then um yeah she like
did the song and it was just fantastic
like she killed it like
it was crazy so how does it feel to be
able to
um connect creatively and to vibe with
someone like that because i
like i mean selena gomez like that's
massive right so when you
you know when it's you and you're like
whoa like muslin gomez reviving right
now
like what is that like it was cool bro i
like
literally i was like a little nervous
like to to face armor the first time
just because um
you know i was just like a little know
it wasn't like crazy nerves but
um but like yeah
and she was just super sweet so like the
nerves like went away in like the first
10 seconds and i was like oh cool she's
like nice
like because i didn't know what to
expect like you know what i mean like i
didn't know if like she was
like gonna be like stuck up or whatever
which
i never thought she would be but like
i've met some people that like surprised
me
um but she dude honestly she's so
so nice it's like yeah hard not to
be stoked about talking to her she's
just so sweet
you